Utah probably isn't the first place that
comes to mind when you think of mummies
but in a pyramid in a warehouse area of
Salt Lake City Summum corporation offers
its customers a very unusual service
we've mummified dogs and cats and birds
beautiful animals to mummified small
rodent type animals I know some kids
that want to have their iguana done you
want to hold hands huh Corky now known
in business as Summum bonum Amin rah
mummified his own pets when they died
his Doberman Pinscher Butch and Oscar
the cat people that have decided to
mummify their animals have developed a
contact a closeness with their pet that
they've been able to share their deepest
sorrows with
she looks just like just like she was
we speak to the animals that they still
are alive because to us they still
really are just exactly like the
Egyptians believed there is really no
such thing as death it's just a
transformation going on to a different
state of consciousness we can set the
animal in any position the owner chooses
Maggie will always remain absolutely
perfect the cost format
Maggie's mummification will be twenty
five thousand dollars which I know is a
lot of money and people are probably
gulping and gasping out there but to me
for the years of devotion and dedication
and service that she gave me and my
family it's insignificant really I I was
going to buy a sports car next year and
and so I made a choice instead of the
sports car it's going to be sick I've
gone through a lot of money on things I
look back that don't even exist anymore
they didn't last this is something like
I'm doing as much for her as I'm doing
it for me it's something I want very
very much
if sick and knew she were being
mummified she would think that that was
the cat's meow
[Music]